yeah you're right to look worried mate
that's a dingo
oh god australia has its very
own wild doggo and it's called the dingo
oh but how deadly is it i'm ann jones
from abc
science and it's my job to watch viral
videos
of dingoes the bastard stole my camera
come on stand still mate just stand
still
don't just don't while you're here if
you like this sort of video
why don't you hit subscribe and that way
you won't miss it when we upload the
next one
let's crack on
my god oh
i want to scratch the belly little white
tootsies but
dingoes are not domestic dogs they're a
wild animal they're closer to the gray
wolves of east asia
than they are to our blue healer right
they will have that more like sort of
greyhound-esque
sort of body that goes really slim in
the abdomen
and pretty agile and muscular looking
legs ready to run around
and on top of that really mobile
joints and that includes their necks
because
unlike domestic dogs a dingo can look
over its shoulder
how you doing oh hello
[Music]
oh look at how cute it is oh
he she it's just used its little schnoot
i read about him in a research paper
that came out of melbourne there's a
dingo
research institute there
oh it's a class
such a complex set of movements it's not
only lifting the latch it's using its
body weight to
push the door but it's the ears that are
the problem mate
see that eager
[Music]
how cool is that that is problem solving
at
its absolute very best tool use
especially spontaneous tool use as in
tool use that isn't
encouraged by humans is a site to behold
an extremely rare and
hasn't been seen in other canines next
one
hey i'm here on gary
and it's really exciting because there
are two dingos and one is coming towards
us
this is one of my videos from fraser
island and luckily i got conway with me
he is going to tell us all about him
[Music]
and they're wangaris in our language ah
wongati
yeah conway burns who is one of the
indigenous rangers who works on the
island
he gave me a lesson or two in wongary
culture
once upon a time there used to be two
types of dingoes here
focus and focus there was a domestic
dingo the camp dengue yeah since all our
old people are gone
they're all wild they're all wangery
they're all wangari on gary there's
apparently like one to two hundred
dingoes and there's about
19 formed packs and within that they'll
have a hierarchy
that is policed constantly those below
will
constantly be trying to rise and those
above will constantly be trying to stay
on top and be the leader of the gang
like when you see them together
it's like watching a soap opera yeah
only one can be top dog
are we still rolling next video
just stand still mate just stand still
good advice
that would be intimidating
don't just don't all that stuff excites
them
no that's okay what happens is sometimes
when they're really excited they'll come
in and nip and bite play for them
involves biting play for them
involves rough housing and things like
that and of course in amongst themselves
they can deal with that but
if we get involved in it it's going to
be a nasty
bite or a nip to one of your limbs the
difference between play and pray
is nothing next one i have lost my
fiance
the poor baby
[Laughter]
maybe the dingo ate your baby
the dingo ate your baby
it was going to come up at some point
right this cultural reference
and i think that that isn't actually
making fun of dingoes it's making fun of
australians
uh yeah look dingos can be aggressive
but they're nowhere near as deadly as
bad acting
[Music]
hi little
oh wait a second that's a whale
they will eat anything dead crabs dead
fish
they'll rip apart coconuts they'll even
eat
uh human poos so if you do have to go to
the toilet when you're on
fraser island you need to bury it really
deep or else
[Music]
i apologize to any cats watching
okay campsite campsite
oh hi i was just uh
i just wanted a cup of tea and i'll take
this as i go
it's easy to be really scared of
something
and demonize something that actually
isn't quite as bad as we might make out
consider this
every single year in australia in public
hospitals
there are something like 12 to 14
000 admissions due to domestic
dog bites so 98 dingo maulings
over the course of 10 years versus that
you can see what's
more deadly yeah let's get another one
in
did you get someone's phone ah
look at those teeth longer than dog
teeth apparently
longer jaw as well what who's that are
they chasing it
i love that the dingo pressed record
[Music]
that was pretty cool right what animal
should we do
next make sure you comment below and
subscribe to abc science
and i'll catch you next time